[موسيقى]
محاولات التقارب المصريه الايرانيه عام
2003 الرئيس المصري حسني مبارك يلتقي
نظيره الايراني محمد خاطمي على هامش قمه
دوليه في جناف عام 2012 زياره الرئيس
المصري محمد مرسي لتهران لحضور فعاليات
قمه دول عدم الانحياز عام 2013 الرئيس
الايراني محمود احمد نجاد في القاهره
لحضور قمه منظمه التعاون الاسلامي عام
2022 الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
يلتقي في بغداد وزير خارجيه ايران حسين
امير عبد الله اياد عام 2023 وزير خارجيه
ايران يشير الى مباحثات للتحقيق التقارب
بين القاهره وطهران عام 2023
برلماني ايراني يؤكد الاتفاق على اعاده
فتح السفارتين في البلدين قريبا
عام 2023 المرشد الايراني يؤكد خلال لقائه
سلطان عمان هيثم بن طارق ان بلاده ترحب
باعاده العلاقات مع مصر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه وال وتقارير الاخباريه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات